next on the list is costume design some
of the women say they like the new sack
dresses it gives them more freedom this
keeps up they're gonna get a lot of them
I don't say a dress should be tight but
I do think when a woman gets into a
dress you ought to have some specific
idea of where she is
now it's a friendly gesture especially
if you happen to know the least they can
do is put in a bookmark
thank goodness Hollywood designers
aren't that way they may put women in
flour sacks but they'll add a little
yeast too it's amazing what they can do
with a needle and thread and a plain
little girl like Zsa Zsa Gabor well back
to work to present the costume design
award to members of the Academy Board of
Governors mr. Robert Ryan and mr.
Wendell quarry
are you ready for this wonderful no you
got dresses no five nominated dresses
will be modeled you describe the dresses
and I'll describe the models I don't
think either one of us should drive
ascribe the dresses you start with the
models okay first it's taina l wearing a
costume design by orry-kelly foreleg
girls
this is just Myrna Hansen wearing an
1860 ball gown designed by Walter
Plunkett for Raintree County
mr. Pat Jones wearing a dress designed
by Edith Head a funny face
as the beautiful miss Victoria Shaw the
ensemble created by Halloween the
picture Pal joy
the lovely Rhonda Fleming wearing an
evening ensemble designed by Charles
lemare for the film and affair to
remember
miss kakari would you like to announce
the winner yes the envelope is in pure
white with a nervous green seal the
winner
hey girls orry-kelly
my thanks to everyone for the special
phase for mr. George Cukor
you